former press secretary Sean Spicer was
under the stars this season a lot of
people complained about him being there
but he made it 8 a long time 8 weeks I
think he received support from the
president here's a look at him dancing
last night
[Music]
John Spicer joins us say sure you did
what you needed to do you went all in
you're a savage I'd love that and you
you lasted about five times as long as
anyone predicted that you would what did
you think of the experience honestly I
had a blast I really really enjoyed this
it exceeded my expectations I went into
this thinking one two weeks maybe I'm
not really good at this but I'll have
fun I'll learn something I made it to
the quarterfinals of this show so and
it's because well I had a tremendous
amount of support I think the president
United States Don jr. so many folks that
came out Jesse Watters and and so many
folks that are friends and supporters
and and made this journey so much fun
but I I loved being part of the show it
was a great experience and I think I'm
better for it so Tom Bergeron is one of
the hosts wrote this kind of I thought
just kind of contemptible complaint
basically about you
going on the show you didn't take
offense you decided not to hold a grudge
you acted like it never happened you
were totally nice you just kept going
and remained positive and I have to say
I was very impressed by that was it hard
to remain positive while you people are
sniping at you well you know it's not
the first time that somebody's kind of
need some negative but I think but I
think that what what I would rather do
is show by lead by and show by example
and what I think I demonstrated is that
we can bring a diverse group of people
together I love supporting conservative
principles and and being a Republican
I'm proud about that but I think that I
want us our side to be better than their
side and come together and show people
that we can fight it out on principles
and policies but be good people come
together and I thought that what this
show does so well is bring these people
together support each other root for
each other leave all of the rest of that
stuff aside and for two hours once a
week everybody gets to be on everybody's
team and cheer for each other
well then you did that I mean you
refused to live
to their expectations of you you refused
to embody their attacks on you you were
relentlessly cheerful to the last minute
no matter what they said or did and I
just thought you know that's that's an
inspiration to people what did Trump say
wouldn't you talk to a Mustang well I
called him he has been super supportive
of me since I left the White House and
then particularly the last nine weeks
and I called him to just express to him
my appreciation for his continued
support the votes are what kept me in
this my my judges scores and my dance
moves were not exactly on the highest
end of the score so I wanted to let him
know how much I appreciated everything
that he and his family did and all of
his supporters for keeping me in this
for nine weeks it's actually
unbelievable I don't think anybody's
ever marshaled the support of the
president of the Unites States you
finally coming back to Washington even
living in a hotel in LA for months well
the nice thing is look I think God
always has a plan tomorrow's my 15th
anniversary to my beautiful wife Rebecca
who is my number one champion so I get
to be home for my anniversary
it just means now I got to find a gift
real quick for you you have a great wine
Oh Rebecca you're the great way
congratulations Sean Spicer good to see
you tonight
thanks Tucker